[Music]
in weird eating habits news submitted by
Terrance peeves reddit users share wrong
and bizarre ways to eat certain foods
wrong ways to eat it yeah yeah is there
a wrong way to eat food like you mean
culturally like if yours will see you
with chopsticks and people are eating
off the floor course that's part of it
too mmm I have everyone that for a lot
of people more like when people oh you
will like use a fork and knife with
pizza or like with a I never the hot dog
who actually said about that people do
they get no it's easy people just love
things to judge people for it
that's so [ __ ] where pretty much I
know so this this was shared on reddit
it was the headline it was called
certain foods have a correct way of
eating them what are some wrong ways to
eat those foods so some examples that
they put in here is this one reddit user
said that his sister has a bizarre way
of eating bananas she will peel the
banana half way and then scrape the
sides with her teeth making it shiny and
then she would eat at the center remains
so before like a corn on the cob
so she's horny and she hasn't gotten any
so like that's her like way I feel like
I'm dealing with it you know you think
she's stimulating some sort of an oral
sex situation I think it's creepy yeah
her teeth though so maybe Kiwis like to
be angry you know Kiwis like how they
have the center part that's sweet and
then the outer parts like more sour so I
used to eat like the outer part first
and then eat just the sweet it doesn't
surprise me to hear that you did
something weird though yes they're like
the shape of it makes it acceptable you
know that behavior another one said that
they once witnessed a friend biting into
an orange like an apple what he didn't
flinch he didn't spit the spit out the
peel he didn't do anything
maybe he played a lot he's there oh yeah
yeah no we do this he's just trying to
be cool
like we would still flinch I'm so bitter
he kept the peel on just like you it
like a bully peeled I mean not filled
unfilled but uh orange orange thank you
you better have really good teeth you
can't do that with some caps and there's
this one there was another one that said
very true
that this kid was eating a watermelon
with the rind and all just eating only
the rind and not the actual center of
the watermelon type of kid I would have
been friends with growing up you know
like we would have been like this well
what kind of what kind of peels do you
know just like how weird and strange
that is it makes no sense if you were
like what's wrong kid I would have been
that kid or been friends with that kid
mm-hmm yeah another one says that they
once had a substitute teacher who just
drank an entire bottle of steak sauce oh
that's creepy it's coming back they
probably put use that as a flask and the
kid just thought of 80 drinks steak
sauce true maybe is your substitute
teacher come on yeah yeah you got a good
point yeah just think somehow he's like
I'm drinking a 100 yeah for sure
I'm a weirdo ha ha yeah another one this
is a cultural one where when you're
eating sushi you have to either stuff
the whole thing in your mouth or hold it
with the chopsticks until it's finished
you're not supposed to fight it and put
it down that is so difficult to do it's
not with the sushi like oh my goodness
like okay first of all you are using
chopsticks yes okay however like to try
to figure out cuz you wanna be like ah
you know and like look it's a hard you
don't have to make a sound I will I do
every time I eat it's like I'm it was so
much fun to go out with in public um but
yeah don't you guys ever feel like it's
like awkward or uncomfortable to use
chopsticks do you eat the whole things
you naughty I ate the whole thing right
the whole dinner yeah I wasn't sure what
the question was
I usually it's the whole thing but
sometimes I go to certain sushi spots
where they put a [ __ ] ton of rice or the
pieces of the fish are really really big
we're like okay I need a bite to do
those specialty roles where it's like
tempura on the outside and it's all
falling apart and there's like so many
sauces that one's harder to eat like all
at once
but ex-boyfriend that would peel
avocados like a banana and just eat it
like like that oh they peel the black
part off and eats around the seat
mmm-hmm interesting and he put like
seasoned salt on it how long did that
last
all right it seems like I can't try that
I have a wife who eats eggs out of a bag
as a snack so it's [ __ ] weird dude
I want that a wife no it's like okay
Trader Joe's has my hard-boiled eggs in
a bag where else do you keep hard-boiled
egg you put in my Tupperware are the
shells and all pre-pre that's good weird
brother
you're weird it's smells dogs my walking
into a Tupperware you put it into a on a
plate no but sometimes she's driving and
eating eggs out of a bag too this is
very weird
I got it you like all that weird yeah we
have early call times here no I know but
it's weird to look at my nephew used to
eat frozen on corn dogs and then put a
bunch of [ __ ] mail on it and just eat
the fries yeah just eat the Mayo and
then he would eat the frozen outside
mm-hm
sounds like you guys were really close
we use a little it's not like 20 another
one here says like a cultural nono is
that once they had Italian a friends
come over and they were making dinner
like the people were making dinner for
the friends and so they the Italian
friends were mortified when they
witnessed them breaking noodles in half
before putting them in the pot because
they're supposed to remain whole I I do
that I do that I think you come at me I
would hell yeah I do I used to do that
you know why easier there's shits long
as [ __ ] takes you forever to spoon it up
boy enjoy just dip it in the pot it's
like exactly sticking out of the water
then I guess like as it cooks it's
supposed to go down but then like what
did it cook a different time it goes
down pretty fast I'm just weightless
spaghetti squash is better for you
anyway whatever Italians don't want
spaghetti anyway it came from China deal
with it yeah it's finally a really good
thing to another one says I knew someone
who would eat a burger layer-by-layer
from top down no I knew someone they'd
do that say oh that's weird
they didn't like um everything being
combined like all the foods because the
whole point it would pizza too they
would take off all the toppings one by
one then the cheese then the that's
weird was this like a friend or no I
mean it was like a should we were at the
same summer camp oh yeah yeah some
people don't like their foods
with other yeah I've seen that mm-hmm
they also mentioned in this thread
eating cereal with ice and I'm like what
I do that with ice with ice ice and
water or just what are you talking about
I think Oh to keep it really really cool
I don't do it anymore
but I used to eat like just you know
regular cereal you're poor you put some
ice cubes in there yes it waters it down
but my mom used to do that for me too
because I hated milk so much so she
would do it so I didn't have to taste
the flavor of the milk huh I'm just
gonna call you weird for that I think
that's okay and then they also and
another weird thing that I guess I think
I do is I eat Kit Kats a certain way so
like first like I'll break off the
KitKat and then I scrape like all the
chocolate stuff and then I end up eating
the wafer by itself mmm I can see why
when you ate Oreos did you break it open
lick the cream out Oreos oh I don't like
Oreos either I used to just like the
cream out and not eat the cookie part
another thing is that I suck on what do
they call it corn nuts corn nuts yeah
yeah yeah corn nuts I can never bite
them cuz they hurt my teeth too much so
I just get the flavor and I throw that
when I played baseball as a kid I would
just suck on sunflower seeds and spit
them out I never even chewed on or
nothing I was too intimidated by by
eating a scene or whatever I was like
this is this is no no it's not gonna
taste and it's somehow like the big kids
they can like crack them without using
their teeth yeah so they're just like
donor mountain like they spit it out and
then since when you're a little kid
you're like I want to fit in it just cut
out the hole that's what I did
so yeah I would pretend to have chewed
it yep yeah anyway and if they would
look at it like why you so weird looking
at my [ __ ] seed for things like that
another one said eating canned soup by
drinking it straight out of the Cadillac
of beverage that's weird
oh yeah eating the entire
artichoke leaf wizard oh yeah yeah about
scraping it entirely but not you don't
no I did not eat that told I met her I
eat I don't even know how to eat that
I eat the sweet potato skin that's fine
okay that's not abnormal I like popcorn
and milk duck
I used to eat the mango skin but I heard
some people do that yeah I mean wait do
you have any weird food things I don't
know I probably do I just I'm not I was
just listening I kind of put be ready
for your [ __ ] questions in a
microwave antenna papa oh that's
actually my grandma loves you can pop
those crazy with popcorn so everyone
thinks that you and I hate each other
oh really when I'm here you're
apparently quiet Oh problem with me G oh
no no no do you I will start throwing
food right now okay I have some sword
ready to go I'm not out on the table
where did you put it anyway
hot tip sit if you put anything in the
microwave you hit the popcorn setting it
will pop hot tip if you put olive oil on
a pan that isn't flat wait no [ __ ]
that's why I caused so much smoke in my
house the other day you know I didn't
know that you could like once you put
olive oil and like this weaboo whatever
the hell you're cooking I didn't know
that it's supposed to have the edges you
know it's that way it all stayed in the
same place like you know a little pool
man upside down no like like okay sorry
let's say this you know so if there's
this as opposed to it being flat you
know it needed to have like that extra I
don't think the visual help me it was
actually really bad visual I have no
other tools really at all that can so
instead of being it was like this
instead of like this but like why why
was the panel put it up well cuz I think
you know it's got the corners where like
the pan goes up like that yeah yeah was
it stuck like on the no I didn't realize
that you had to have the curved one I
just thought oh all of it just like
cooks normally like if you put olive oil
on top well like a flat pan like yeah
don't be as and stuff like the flat flat
one yeah pancakes I did that was a
griddle olive oil got all in the oven
and it was all hot and smoke was
everywhere and I was like oh I guess I
shouldn't have done you had pans without
the
is Gribble over not ever the regular
fans like you just thought that was a
great olive oil the griddle by the way
was there anything on it it sounds like
you just put [ __ ] olive oil on the
other okay thank you yeah I thought you
just put that [ __ ] down and you're like
why it's all smoke my house said yeah
how am I gonna eat you're talking about
a baking sheet that's what it was a
baking bread of a baking pan yeah my
college opponent oh why do they like
olive oil so it was just like everywhere
yeah I had to open every window at my
place yeah it was bad I learned a lesson
how's the squash it's so good
[Music]